question
our speaker will be
uh
manfred warmuth from google research and
he will be presenting bayesian property
calculus for density matrices
okay
uh thanks tom for inviting me
um
[Music]
so i will talk about
how we got there basically
we used to reason with probability
vectors in quantum physics you reason
with density matrices
and i claim that we have a base rule for
density matrices
so i have lots of pictures
so hopefully i'll stay at a high enough
level to explain it
so where do i come from
i come from machine learning
where you have a bunch of models i
experts
and then you maintain a weight vector on
those experts
so
your new weight is the old weight times
e to the minus loss in the current
iteration
if your loss is very large your weight
goes down by a multiplicative factor
this is a positive factor
if it is small
then it
goes up or depending we always keep
normalized weights
okay so if you're not familiar with this
there's a special case that you are
familiar with if which is bayes rule
bayes rule happens when you have your
loss
have
minus log the conditional probabilities
data likelihoods
then and eta is one then this is pulled
down and it becomes this
and this is the normal base rule
okay
now in machine learning we're very much
interested in
also how to motivate the update what's
the measure of progress what's the
regularization and it turns out bayes
rule the regularization is a relative
entropy
or it's based on the max end principle
and i'm going to generalize all that i'm
going to use the quantum relative
entropy to divide a new rule
and it's kind of a wild write but i'm
talking about very basic six i'm not
talking about graphical models yet
i'm talking about
how would you define conditional
probabilities how would you define the
bayes rule when you have density
matrices
okay
good so
in machine learning we ran into density
matrices because we want to keep track
of subspaces it's a little bit
complicated to explain
it
you run into that when you want to learn
principle component analysis then you
want to have the
the subspace with the largest variance
and there we ran into an update
which was
volt density matrix take a matrix log
subtract
the loss
the gradient of a loss or the loss
and then matrix exponentiated and
normalized and that's your new density
matrix
so we ran into this density matrix
parameter
and then we asked ourselves the question
what corresponds to base
and then we ran into a certain update
that is interesting
okay
good
so i'm going to visualize things a lot
i'm going to visualize symmetric
matrices and so forth
and i use these plots
um
you have a symmetric matrix or a
positive definite matrix
and
you multiply
this is the unit sphere i can only plot
it in two dimensions for now
and then this point is s times u
okay that's how i visualize the metric
matrix and of course
the eigenvalues then this is a straight
line
right because you have this
they're the axis of the ellipse
now there's a very important one
which is the degenerate ellipse we call
it a dyad
i don't work with cat symbols it would
be kept times cat transpose or one of
those right it's an outer product
uu transpose
it's
you have one it's a density matrix a
degenerate density matrix with one
direction where it's one the eigenvalue
is one and all the other eigenvalues are
zero
that's sort of the notion of a state
you'll see
so now let me give you a big picture the
way
i was putting this together
you have real vectors
then you take um coefficient vectors
times unit vectors
right and then becomes a vector
in symmetric matrix you take
eigenvalue times
uh times these diets or
linear combination of diets
yes it's a joint i i gave this talk to
machine learners so you have to replace
a joint
uh
transpose with a joint uh you have to
replace uh symmetric matrices with
emission matrices all of that there's no
difference so i
sorry i didn't change my slides for this
quantum thing here sorry
so now for probability vectors
you have weights times the unit vector
and now these are mixture coefficients
they're non-negative and sum to one
they're still vectors
okay and then for density matrix you
take a mixture
of
diets
and i have pictures of this in a moment
okay so that's sort of the overall
picture
and
we're going to argue today of course
that density matrices are
generalized distributions that's of
course boring to most of you but i don't
know i just go over it again
so that what central very often is
the the basic case
this case in this case is a special case
when you replace your unit vector by
eiei transpose in other words instead of
writing
writing things as vectors
i write it as a diagonal matrix
with a fixed eigensystem
we do that a lot okay
that's sort of
a general thing okay so now i've got to
talk about conventional and generalized
probabilities a little bit
so the elementary events
in normal probability are units
and in a finite case i could do this
whole thing with continuous case but
it's just not the point
so assume you have a hundred very 100
elementary events and then
the elementary event would be a unit
vector a unit or then if you write it as
eiei transpose
it looks like this
pictorially it's the axis
fixed eigen system
okay so in the general case the diodes
can be in any direction anything with
unit bond
those are the diets
and we prefer to use i prefer to use
these diets instead of the unit vectors
okay so now what is an event
again i already talked about an
elementary event
and then an event would be
you have a u u transpose and then here
you have a subset
of the
eigenvalues that are that are one
if you took the normal probability
theory would be this would be identity
it's just a subset
of elementary events okay so you can
write it of course using a sum of diets
good
now a density matrix is the same object
except the eigenvalues in here
they're non-negative and sum to one
right or you write it as a mixture of
diets
okay
so if you would want to do
graphical models with density matrices
this would be your basic object i claim
so
you write a mixture down and the
dimension here is two and you write down
three mixtures
you can write it as a matrix this is a
positive definite matrix
and
plot looks like this and it decomposes
into dimension many eigen diets
so now
symmetric matrices symmetric positive
definite matrix you can view them as
covariance matrices
that's kind of curious i don't know why
this is the case but it just happens to
be
there's a cost vector and then your
matrix
would be this covariance
and now the interesting thing is
the variance along a vector u
which would be this object
happens to become u covariance u
transpose coherent matrix u or you can
write it in many different ways this way
you can write it as a trace
right
so that's going to be the assignment of
probabilities sorry i'm in the way
okay
i can plot this
so here's the origin
here's the unit ball
here is
the the density matrix viewed as an
ellipse in red
and then
the dot product the probability assigned
to this particular direction happens to
be the blue one
it's the variance
you get these beautiful plots
here some two dimensional ones
and the curious thing about these things
is
that if you take the probabilities these
are the probabilities right
the probability assigned to u1 which is
the same as the probability assigned to
minus u1
and if you take these probabilities
and you take two orthogonal ones they
sum to one in three dimensions
whatever however you you you rotate this
i i don't know how to do this the
physicists know how to do this sorry
like this right
wherever you rotate this
um the three sum to one
and that's a
consequence of gleason's theorem and so
forth we'll see in a moment
actually here it is gleason theorem says
whenever you
have some kind of a function
unit directions to probabilities between
0 and 1
such that
if you take an orthogonal orthogonal
basis it sums to one
then when the dimension is larger than
three the object has to be
described
using this density matrix
that's decent theorem
so i don't know the proof is a couple of
pages but i don't even understand the
proof but i just took it for given
by the way this is joint work with uh
dima kuzman very smart phd student in
santa cruz and i was there he's now also
at google
now
this orthogonality this orthogonality
genera generalizes disjointness
when things are in the same eigen system
let's say i i take a dot product between
two matrices
and then the same eigen system then
[Music]
this dot product being this trace being
zero
corresponds to the
the vectors
these two vectors being disjoined so
view
orthogonality is somehow a general a
fancy generalization of disjointness
when you're in the same eigen system it
becomes disjointness
but when you're in
when the when the two objects are of
different eigen system it's of course
much more sophisticated
now what's this trace
that we use often that becomes our dot
product in machine learning you always
have to have a dot product usually start
product between vectors now we have dot
products between matrices
so
what's that
so if this is one of those event
matrices which was a
symmetric positive definite matrix with
some zeros and ones along the diagonal
then you can write this trace in various
ways one way is
you can pull out a probability
which comes from
the
density matrix the eigenvalue
times the variance along a certain
direction
that's an expected variance
you can also have you can also see that
the trace acts like an expectation in
some sense
you have a random variable
which is a symmetric
matrix
then you can expand over
the sigma eyes
and then this is again a probability via
this rule here
i said whenever you take author when you
ever expand the probabilities of an
orthogonal basis they sum to one
which is here in orthogonal basis
descends to one
and then times an outcome so it becomes
an expected outcome
in
quantum physics
we use measurements so in my notation
i'm drawing this to contrast what i do
is different
and i don't understand
fully everything of course okay so
you have a mixture state
that's your density matrix
positive definite density matrix
and then you have an observable
and then after the measurement
you collapse
into one of these diets
or a mixture of those diets
and
this particular diet happens with this
probability
so you go from here
to here and this is your successor
density matrix
and there's also an outcome and the
trace is an expected outcome
in my base rule we are not going to
collapse
but nevertheless it's the natural thing
that corresponds to reasoning with
density matrices
so that's what i want to get feedback
from
from you you'll see
okay so more pictures
so the question is what does it all mean
so first i'm now going to explain the
normal base rule
in pictures
you have some models chosen with some
prior probability
and then a datum is generated it's a
data likelihood
and
then this would be
the the theorem of total probability
which sits down here
and
the bayes rule is this you take prior
times data likelihood over normalization
in pictures
so this is your prior
this is your data likelihood
okay this is the first posterior
so i multiply this times this this times
this this times this i normalize and i
end up with this notice
that there was a high likelihood over
here
so this bar is pulled up and if we keep
on iterating that it's going to go up
higher and higher
second time apply the same
data likelihood
third time fourth time you see
so essentially this is a soft max
you base as a soft max
because if you would iterate it you
would go to the maximum likelihood but
it's soft because there's a relative
entropy there it's a regularizer you'll
see yes
do you want us to think of this
should we think this is seeing the same
data point four times or is it just
abstractly no no no it actually is the
exact plot and i will put another
visualization in a moment and i will
show you what my quantum based rule is
and it's related
okay the kind of base rule
for now what happens is
it happens to be a density matrix which
is red
a data
symmetric data likelihood matrix which
is this
then
you take a matrix log of both you add
this is commutativity you will see that
in a moment then your matrix
exponentiate now to show you in pictures
what happens when you have iterate that
make that update
it
also does a max
and it goes to the maximum eigenvalue
of this matrix
go back
what happened
so you see initially the posterior
wasn't aligned with a maximum axis
but it's gradually
moved to the maximum axis of the data
likelihood matrix
in the diagonal case you just go to the
maximum now you go to the maximum
eigenvalue
and this is just um
this this operation here
is just mathematically totally beautiful
and puzzling
and it hits the spot
um
in many ways okay so that's what i will
try to convince you
everybody understand so
it's this if you if you remember one
thing in this talk is
view
based this way as of soft max
and this is a soft max
eigenvalue calculation here's your
question yes what is the data likelihood
matrix
uh it's a
a symmetric matrix i will talk about
that in a moment
what these things are we back engineered
it or everything right but then it's
somehow fit
so now i show you what an evolution of
this iterative update work works does in
a different way
and
imagine you have
three
three experts one at concentration one
point four point three a little bit less
than point three and a very small one
and the fitness vector the likelihood
vector is of this one is point eight
four the factor by which you multiply
this 1.85 and this 1.9 is 0.7
so when you iterate this 1 times 2 times
3 times
this one
is pulled up
it
it is beaten by 0.5 0.85 because it's a
little bit larger but then the 0.9 comes
in and beats them both
okay
now this is the most difficult plot in
some sense what i do now is
instead of i do it in the matrix case
here
here the concentration vector
and the fitness vector they are the same
eigen system
and then this calculation here is rather
slow
but if they are offset if they rotate it
a little bit it happens faster
if everything is happens faster if i
extend to positive and negative negative
infinity
this is the diagonal case
and this is the case where you have an
additional rotation in there
so somehow
the the base rule when they are off
okay when you're in pictures
when i want to do this calculation
and
the red and the green matrix are in the
eigen same eigen system then the
computation goes to slowest
if they're slightly off
then i home into the maximum eigenvector
faster
and that's the promise for me as a
machine learner of the quantum i kind of
go around things and i converge faster
and i'm really fascinated by this
yes i can repeat what you say
okay what i said
if
red and green are in the same eigen
system
then this iterative process of going to
the maximum
is slow
if however they're in a different eigen
system so these are rotated red and
green is
the axis of this is this and the axis of
red is this if they're not in the same
they don't have the same axis
then the maximum calculation is faster
that shows up here
in these two
plots okay
you still have a video everybody okay
good
it's an unusual talk i apologize
so uh
normal
bayes rule
you can write it we're going to write
everything diagonally right
so it's the data likelihood and now that
posterior
prior data likelihood normalization
what that means in machine learning
would be you start with a prior
then you have a data likelihood oh it
stretches this a little bit longer the
posterior goes a little bit bigger in
this direction here another further
stretch oh wow
now it goes fatter this way it gets a
little fatter i react to
you see this is online learning that's
my background
now when i do the
what i call quantum based rule but
when i send oh i sent this to a journal
and we call it quantum base rule
and i i got such complicated reviews
about
you know philosophizing in so many
different ways it was just
amazing um
quantum
kind of makes people's heart pulse
so then
we were a little bit more careful with
our language
okay so now in the situation is
you have a little bit of a rotation you
see and it reacts
and then here it reacts back
and it reacts back you see what i'm
saying
so that's the kind of thing we're
interested in these updates
and what's the regularizer and so forth
okay so so far i have a nifty
generalization yes
so do these updates commute yes
you you you will commutation is very
important okay you will see it first of
all when i multiply two matrices they
don't commute that's the first thing i
have to solve
right and then yeah okay yes
good point you're getting there right
there
so here's your my update
so this is symmetric positive definite
it doesn't even have to be normalized to
one
well the eigenvalue is sum to one okay
symmetric point and eigenvalue is
something one and then here i just have
to have symmetric positive definite
typically the range is bounded
but you can also normalize when the
range is not bounded
okay and now the picture goes like this
you see
uh you start out with symmetric positive
definite symmetric positive definite
then you take logs you get symmetric
then you get addition that's the
commutativity essentially you will see
in a moment
and then your matrix exponentially you
get symmetric positive definite divide
by one you get a density matrix
so it is in some sense
a generalization of an intersection you
will see this factorial in a moment
and
when i multiply
two vectors and to compute
to compute
the bayes rule
when one of the guys is zero it's zero
and only in the when
in the support if your intersection the
the the posterior lives in the
intersection of the support
right only this guy is nonzero and this
happens
also for the other page
rule
log a
log b
so a a is
red
green and the result lives in the
intersection
this year
okay
okay um
let me skip well okay let's talk about
that too okay
so i was here was interested in traces
when the two guys have the same eigen
system then there's a lot of interaction
in the dot product
when they have the different eigen
system then this measure this matrix the
density matrix doesn't even see much
of these two
it cannot distinguish between this and
this as long as they have the same trace
it's the same the result is the same
so when this one is
in our basic eigen system and this one
is harder marked
in some sense you don't see it the dot
product doesn't see it
right this is
fundamental in all of
quantum computation
now here's a lead authorization
of this product you can write this as a
limit
of a to the n b to the n power n
very fascinating
and if you write this limit as a circle
dot
then the base rule becomes this
quantum base rule
it's just a funny product
now the structuralization i was
fascinated by that so we
we visualized it
so if this is
a
two symmetric matrices
then if you take that product
it might not be symmetric and it also is
not positive definite you get these
negative parts
but if you take the circle dot it
actually is
symmetric
and you see this
here's a b
b a
a half b a half a i have b a half's
and then b a half a half b a half a half
they get this gets smaller and more
symmetric and if you do it infinitely
often
you end up with this
there is another cauterization which i
only discovered later
where you pull one half out then the
symmetry part is already
taken care of but
so it as you go on you get more and more
symmetric and more and more positive
definite
you can do it with rabbits
so this is
a
b
this is this famous stanford rabbit b
a
and they look different
but if you do a half b a half and so
forth if they already look more and more
alike and do it very slowly then it
becomes commutative
right you ask that question creativity
so this is about commutativity so
as many properties
intersection properties commute
uh relates to determinants
okay
now some other basic things theorem of
total probability
what's the theorem of total probability
it's even before bayes rule
you have this is your whole space you
want look at the event y and this is a
subsection
into different areas depending on the
models
and then the probability of this is
equal to the sum
uh
you know
it's like the conditionals are summed up
right
pmi times uh
which is this area times how much in
that area is y
it's this area times how much in the
area is y it's this area times how much
in the area is y summed up and then you
get total probability
okay
so
we generalize this
using our operation
it becomes an o dot
and a trace
and we generalize the whole calculus but
i don't know whether it's real that's my
last open problem you'll see in a moment
that's why i'm
i'm talking here i hope somebody will
prove it to me
is there a real phenomenon that does it
so you
you have the theorem total probability
it's still upper bounded by traces
there's some famous inequalities there
and
[Music]
yes
so
now we were fascinated because we're
machine learners we're online learners
uh
what is the
what is this generalization too and then
everything we looked at generalizes
the fundamental thing of base is
um
you want to
approximate your p of y by
p of y
p of mi of a particular model times the
data likelihood that's a lower a lower
bound
that corresponds to the map estimator
you take minus log in front the minus
log of p of y
is equal to
the minimum of
the pri minus log of the prior
probability minus the data likelihood
this is sort of the fundamental bound
that you will overdo you you have a fat
solution you throw everything away and
you and then you have products and then
the logs
become
sums that
basic calculation that kind of bounding
style that you and doing base a lot
happens again for this
case uh you have to use a few
inequalities and again here is sort of
the
the prior
data likelihood and you have to minimize
over direction as well
so it goes on and on and on
okay machine learning
we don't just care about the update we
want to have
what is the regularization what holds
the update back
and that here is a relative entropy
so i explained we derive all updates
usually in terms of a minimum of a
regularizer often the breakdown
divergence plus either times loss
okay and um
we're going to explain bayes rule this
way now
when you put your relative entropy you
get the exponential gradient algorithm
when you put euclidean distance squared
and minimize you get gradient descent
back problem
so what we how do we derive
phase rule normal base rule
mix a relative entropy to
the prior
minus
an expected log likelihood
if you said eta to infinity
which means which corresponds to you
iterate the thing very often or then you
listen to that loss a lot
because this one is wiped out
and then you just go to the maximum
and this either controls the soft max
and you can solve this
you add a constraint
a lagrangian that the coefficients have
to sum to one and then you do a little
calculation then you get bayes rule with
an eta parameter which is a time
parameter
if you said eight out to one you get the
normal base rule
so does everybody understand this so i
i'm interested in deriving the updates
why because this is now my regularized
it also becomes my measure of progress
it becomes my inertia term
the bounds will when you prove things
this would be central in in the in the
proofs
so i need to know the inertial term
and the fundamental thing is nature when
it uses bayes rule implicitly works with
entropies why i don't know i will show
you later a way of running
bayes rule in your kitchen with 10 to
the 15 variables if you have a pcr
little thing but
that's all you need
but
i don't know whether the quantum base
looks real
okay so that's the update now
you can also view take the relative
entry apart and have two terms this is
the data likelihood and this is the
initial data
and then it becomes the regularize it
becomes a an entropy so it's the max end
principle it depends on what you like
the max n principle or the minimum
relative integrand so it's it's kolbach
versus jane's
how do we end up with a quantum rule
well we plug in the quantum relative
entropy
also sometimes called the van neumann
entropy and it has various other names
it was a japanese guy forgot the name
and
and then you have to have a fancier
mixture for the log for the expected log
likelihood you do the same thing
you get the normal base the base rule
that i had
and eight with when you use eta equals
one
is that clear
so that's how you can derive these
updates from first principles from from
from
you look all natural distributions are
derived
using this kind of principle minimizing
entropy subject to constraints the
gaussian is something the you know
exponential distribution is something
it's very very very fundamental in
probability theory
and we just use the same thing to get a
quantum base rule
okay
here
you can also split off the quantum
entropy
and this is the initial data and the
data
like
data likelihood
okay
good
now where do those conditional things
come from
i think it's very complicated and this
is a
kind of a
horrendous paper in the sense that
i've done this a while back
but if i really want to understand the
details i have to study it
even though it's my own people
so you have to uh
in general whenever you have to uh
have a y space and an m space and in the
binary case it's very simple the
elementary means for the cross space is
a i times b j
it gets much more complicated in the
quantum case
what i call quantum case because you're
kind of petition you can have
entanglement
the upshot is
and then there's lots of these traces
you get rules of the following type and
there's about 20 of them
and
this is marginalization you use partial
trace
okay
uh here is another bayes rule that
already was developed developed by serf
and adami he's they were at caltech i
think they're physicists
we found their rule as a special case of
our of our calculus
um this is the theorem of total
probability
these are the flavors of the things you
get this is another base rule
the basal that i showed you
and there is another one here
so we have a whole calculus so i claim
that this is the right calculus to use
it's complicated maybe it can be
simplified and so forth but um
it's kind of curious so we
we maintain uncertainty about the
direction
of
maximum variance
using a density matrix
we update it we develop and update
generalize the conventional bayes rule
we can motivate it using the max end
principle and we developed the calculus
okay we used this
if there was other matrix classes we
used we used already this calculus in
rudimentary ways only we didn't need
fancy calculus but
we used the density matrix as a
parameter for pca
but we're looking for other applications
now
here's my open problem one
i have two open problems for you
open problem one is is it real now it
turns out normal base rule
is real in the following sense
assume
i have 10 to the 15 rna strands in here
different rna strands in here with
certain concentrations and i want to
select a strand that attaches to a
surface of a protein this is kind of
drug design application you need that
you need to
have the uh
first you need to have attachment
okay so you tip your sheet of protein
into the soup
you pull it out
you wash it off
and then you apply pcr to duplicate
the rna strands you have to convert the
dna and then you apply pcr and you
convert back to rna
and
you basically you can convince yourself
very quickly that you're implementing
bayes rule with 10 to the 15 variables
and i had my scientist parties where
people
in my kitchen uh uh played around and
extracted
you know the dna from
from onions and did all these
experiments so it was interesting
so you can do this with very basic
equipment that is very popular now
because of because of the culvert
epidemic
okay so it can it cannot be done with a
computer
um
because you have to do three dimensional
simulations with
10 to the 15 variables
okay
now
the point and i want to make here is
bayes rule is real
it happens you can also do it in your
sandbox
where
instead of
pulling pushing in pulling out washing
off blah you you use a filter
sieve to sieve out different different
types of kernels
that would be the selection operator now
in the case of sand you cannot make more
of it of the same type so
in pcr you can
but the question is
what about this one
is it real
is there a physical
experiment that
updates this way
is there a physical experiment that
homes into the largest eigenvalue
can you think of one that's that's what
i want to know
that's problem one
the second one
is
the
general generalized space you always
contains the conventional base rule as a
hardest case
so the hardest case happens always when
they are the two matrices of the same
eigen system
so
so in some sense you learn the eigen
system for free and we're totally fast
and fascinated by that as a pun we call
it a free matrix lunge
because
there is a paper out there that says you
know there's no free lunch in machine
learning every algorithm has some
advantages and disadvantages there's no
free lunch you when you pick a different
algorithm you win in some areas but you
have to lose in another area it's a
dubious paper
but it's a nice phrase
so we we as a pun
we said oh we have the free matrix lunch
we proved certain regret bounds for
certain algorithms in the matrix case
they had and the hardest case was the
diagonal case the basic case and we ran
into a bunch of these
and we're kind of fascinated when is
that
okay anyway we had fun as you can tell
so that's it
[Applause]
yes
so
thanks for this talk i i won't pretend
that was able to follow everything but
but
um
one thing that confuses me a bit about
this the whole program here is so so
clearly things happen in quantum that
don't happen in standard probability and
people have exploited that for fun and
profit you know shaw's algorithm uses
destructive interference and all these
things and so it seems to me maybe i
misunderstood that you're just trying to
generalize probability calculus kind of
trying to keep as much classical
behavior as possible and so my question
is is that right i mean like like what
criteria do we use to decide how to
generalize basically so you have this
product that commutes like do we want it
to commute it's from my background
from my background i sort of ran into
this base rule people with different
backgrounds ran into other bayes rule
the question is which one is real
if you talk about something like
graphical models right
like the first the talks this morning
graphical models they use bayes rule and
so forth and this one fits
whether other ones fit as well i don't
know
okay but uh i don't have an answer
okay
but i would love to know what you should
be looking for if you were a physicist
this experiment
you know with a with an eigen system
is there an experiment where you would
home into the largest eigen direction
after iterating
that's what i would look for some kind
of a physical experiment
okay
thank you i don't know whether it exists
[Music]
i'm very fascinated by it though because
i mean this is only the beginning
trust me there's lots of beautiful
calculus there
that makes things work
so and it looks like information here it
looks like covers book
except lift it
to the density matrix case
i can do mutual information i could you
know i could continue
can i ask do the other base rules have a
similar
interpretation that something
converges
in the way that the maximum eigenvalue
seems to converge here
what
yes i would say so i mean
it's this
it's this where you
you know these are your models and then
you home into the largest and then
this is the generalization
i mean in the other you said there were
alternative phase rules and you showed a
couple on the calculus slide uh those
are
yes uh those are just sort of different
questions but they use the same
same kind of thinking
uh in in this uh they're not different
they are
of the type that we discussed that we
found they're all sort of relative entry
be motivated
but they're
other people have looked at
phase rule defined base rule in the
quantum context and they came up with
totally different answers
which i don't recall right now but back
then i read a bunch of them and
they didn't make much sense to me
questions
this is a slightly impressionistic
question yes um
you mentioned you know if you use the
kind of fun neumann formulization for
quantum mechanics you you collapse
and you just go to an eigenstate right
and you throw away the rest of it and
you were saying you don't throw away the
rest of it right well if you run if you
run
let me see if you run this for a very
long time
you end up with one state
right but the i mean i mean the question
you you you said that there's a
you get an equal result by taking a
limit as n goes to infinity of taking
essentially milder and milder
transformations right and iterating them
when you when you define your circle dot
thing that's just a different way to
define one update yeah but i'm but in in
quantum mechanics it seems to me that's
the analog of what's called the quantum
zeno effect which if you're using if
you're using the von neumann collapse
rule and you try and
and and get to a large transformation by
a series of small transformations it
doesn't work you get stuck because
you're throwing away the other stuff
right it's it's the watchpot watch pot
um um paradox that if you if you
if you observe it too closely and you're
modeling the observations by von neumann
collapses
you don't get the results of a
of a large
thing by a series of small things it
gets stuck
so is that i mean you is it that you're
not getting that because you're not
throwing stuff away i mean there's maybe
collapse yeah i don't know okay
yeah so so yes yeah that kind of
thinking
is interesting yeah
any questions
i have a small question i just like your
picture i just can you just remind us
how you draw the
matrix that looks like an eight what
what does that mean
if you look at their funny product
definition there's a bunch of those you
mean this one
the eight yeah i have to go go
yeah okay that's here
yeah yeah something we plotted these
with matlab and maple
so what i did here is
here's the unit direction
this is the density matrix
and then i plotted
the trace of
c u u transpose in the direction of u
so i plotted this this length
is this oh i see i see
so this would be the probability
assigned to that state
as i look at all possible directions
gotcha and then it looks like this
any questions
all right let's take a speaker thank you